hello and welcome to the agenda we're
here in Brussels for let's take a look
at what's happening next week at the
plenary in Strasbourg last year the
civil liberties committee held at 15
meetings to try to get to the bottom
other NSA hacking round is now time for
any PS to approve the recommendations of
the inquiry but what could help to
create stricter privacy laws and new
rules on data protection two new reports
aim to control how our information is
shared and protected and part of the new
laws specifically point to the NSA
hacking rao new provisions would force
foreign companies to submit requests to
access data and not just take it find
out how both votes go on wednesday could
the arbitrary powers the troika be at an
end mep s have been looking into the
governance and the social impact of the
austerity programs pushed through by the
European Commission International
Monetary Fund and European Central Bank
now they vote to improve a more
democratic mandate including the
long-term involvement of the Parliament
the resolution to kick out the
Commission's proposal on seed regulation
goes up before a full plenary farmers
citizens activists across the EU went up
in arms over the curbs on biodiversity
and freedom of choice and the
agricultural committee followed suit
voting to reject the proposal on the
grounds it would give the Commission too
much power find out more at the vote on
Thursday and that's all we have for this
agenda take care and enjoy the week